his last chance yeah but this does allow
the queen to dive in grab a pawn attack
the rook where's the rook going to move
i mean okay well okay attacks the queen
and uh well i suspect that the queen
okay we see a check first this is a nice
strategy and uh he's just winning ivanka
king the king can't move has three
pieces two bishops and a knight for two
white rooks but look at white's rook in
the corner stuck next to his king look
how open the king is on the diagonals
dude knows he's done this attack is
going to be deadly he's not going to
survive that white king it's living on
borrowed time
i mean
all it needs is a dark square bishop to
come into the game and look it's game
over and now a knight is in
and there's is there a big threat in the
in the position yeah there's a couple of
big threats black's queen now uh is
threatened to come down to the bottom of
the board and that would end in disaster
for white look how white's queen is cut
off from the defense of her king that
black knight in the centre of the board
acting as a defender and an attacker
look at that smile on
the champion's face magnus carlsen wins
the charity cup in thai breaks after a
tough fight against john christophe duda
look at that it's nice to see that smile
probably a little bit tired
but
impressive stuff by magnus carlsen look
at that what is that smile about david